You see an Asold trying to go into a Pokemon. Yeah, I might I
don't even know if I have the timeline on this timeline on this
correct, but is it Pokemon said something about Syuno
and they like popped off on her for it. I don't even know if
I want to watch the original clip. Yeah, I'll watch the original
clip. It's this clip. This clip is uh this clip's going nuclear.
>> You guys seen this clip? This clip's gone nuclear. This
is the patented
40 spike move. Okay, she's going to make everybody just totally
flip out.
Get ready for it.
Was she actually rage baiting? No. I actually think this is one
of those ones where I think I could take her side. I think I'll
be honest, I've only watched this clip through other people,
so I'm not even sure how I'll feel about it watching it myself.
>> Actually, uh, speaking of opinions, there is one there
is one thing I'm willing to share my opinion on.
Um,
I saw Syuno's back.
>> Syuno's back
a month, a month and a half.
>> I've spent longer getting over situationships. I'm not
joking.
>> He said, >> "Okay, so giggle."
beg posting followed by the word situationship followed by that
giggle. I can already tell Teone has like smashed a hole in his
wall. Okay,
Tekone literally watched this and smashed a hole in his wall
like immediately. He just could not help himself.
Big hole in the wall. >> At three sentences, few week vacation.
>> I'm good.
God bless. God bless.
Don't worry, guys.
No, that's all I'll say.
I want to feel your body, right?
It's okay if Clippers hate me as long as I feel like I said what
I meant and I meant what I said.
>> there will be. And that's what's going to happen nine
times out of 10. One time out of 10 I might be like, "Oh, I didn't
say that the way that I meant." >> Oh, Teone's on a break
or something. He hasn't posted on YouTube in two weeks. I
>> but okay. So,
listen, I'll be real. People were not happy about that. I I guess
I don't disagree. Like, I think Syikuno got off pretty light
for what he was doing, but I also think it's all social consequences
anyway. It's like pretty light. It's like I just don't really
see it. Maybe it's not light at all. Actually, I take that back
immediately. I think it's just all social consequences, but that's
all I would expect is him to have social consequences. It's not
like he did anything illegal. It's not like they can ban him.
I don't really think he had anything approaching like a assault
allegation, nothing like that. So, realistically, I just think
it's fine that people know that that's the way he
Yeah, I did think he's like kind of a scumbag, but realistically,
scumbags get to do their jobs and work. So, it is what it is,
right? It is what it is. No, he's not a That's actually the wrong
read, but I'm just not going to get back into it.
He is actually minimizing what he does. But it's I'm not even
going to get into it cuz I already had the arguments with stream
and I was proven right like time and time again with new and
newer and newer information. So, we don't have to have that fight
anymore. I won that fight already. I don't need to have that
fight again. Massive scumbag, serial liar, and cheater who hit
his girlfriend to my teenagers. Yeah, I'm good on that. Yeah,
it's like it's it's just it's a little too light. It's a little
too light to explain it. You would basically imply like somebody
who does this with a couple girls. This guy was doing it at like
an industrial scale in a way that was very very different. And
yeah, it's just it's just different. But it's like there's nothing
you can really do. It's not like I want him to go away for longer
than a month. It's like he's got to do his job. He's got to work.
He's not like a huge streamer anymore, so he can't just take
a ton of time off, right? in the in the way he used to be able
to like it's a different situation he's in now in my opinion.
So yeah, it is what it is.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see here. So we had this clip. Okay. Now the
XQC and Asminold responses were something to behold. Hold on.
Let's see >> Speaking of opin,
there is one there is one thing I'm willing to share my opinion
on.
Oh, what is that?
>> Um,
I saw Syuno's back.
I've spent longer getting over situationships. I'm not joking.
>> Okay, chat. I wasn't going to form drama or be mad at
Pokei for anything. I don't care. I mean, she can have her own
stream and do what what she says. Whatever she just said is so
is so like I I can't I I'm afraid of using
>> He didn't even listen. He couldn't even listen. It's
like her mannerisms infuriate people. Just her mannerisms alone
send people into like a m like a frothing rage. It's so funny.
>> I'm like >> whatever the SHE JUST SAID
WHATEVER the she just said.
>> He said three sentences few week
I'm good. >> Okay. It's performative as one we don't know
the extent of the problem. two, we don't know how it affects
uh uh him or her and and the root of the problem and or the root
behavior that that's the problem. We have no idea what that what
that is like. We only all we have is the extension of all those
things and how it portrayed itself on social media through the
mouths of other people who had something to gain from it MIGHT
BE ON SOME GUY'S VIDEO with even more. So at that point
>> that's actually not that's not true. I mean you could
just read all the source material
and you could judge it as it comes through. He's saying like,
"Oh, you don't even know the real truth because all you know
is what people put on the internet." And it's like, "Well, yeah,
but some people it's a pretty thorough documentation."
Like maybe it's all misrepresented, but I thought some people
were obviously imbalanced. Like the He-Mal person obviously imbalanced
in in how she was portraying it. And then there's the what Iceland
person who's obviously very balanced. I thought >> we're
getting the absolute most diluted version of what we think is
the truth. And we're going to judge somebody because after a
month based off that diluted information really. And we're gonna
make an assumption about him. No. No. We're not gonna do that.
We're not do that.
>> God bless. God bless.
>> You know what I mean? >> You know what I mean?
>> Don't worry, guys.
I feel like this is almost like a want for somebody to be cancelled
and to be like so GG they cannot recover and to not be able and
not be able to have like any income or to lose from an event.
Like it is what it is. Like like I feel like this almost almost
like uh uh upset
>> that the power that you think that outrage has isn't
having an effect in real time and oh no like go back and what
is that? >> No, that's all I'll say. >> It's like
it's vindictive.
It's okay if Clippers hate me as long as I feel like I said what
I meant and I meant what I said. >> I'm not doing anything
like we know. I'm I'm just saying we don't know what the extent
of those things are. The the only that I always talk about is
when people get banned, how long they get banned for, a day for
something like if somebody takes a break or somebody says I need
to work on myself and comes back and it's it's a it's a month.
Okay, XC's take is not that funny. Asmin Gold is way better.
Actually, we'll do the XC reaction. into the Asmin Gold reaction
real quick because that's that probably gets the last two pieces.
I just want to go over it. It was it was a little funny right
off right off the bat. I saw this on Twitter today. Okay. >> Like
who knows?
>> I've spent longer getting over situationships. I'm not
joking.
>> You still have situationships.
>> Yo yo yo yo. Are you 30 years old? You still having
situationships?
Old
old three sentences few week
>> I'm good.
>> God bless. God bless.
>> You know what really annoys me about Pokemon is that
you
you just know you just know Asmin Gold doesn't get like spiked
quite the same way, but you can just tell it actually annoys
me about this person. He's like trying to stay calm. the performative
calm. I could just tell he's about to throw a bomb right now.
Okay.
>> You know what really annoys me about Pokemon is that
you can you can tell that she is probably the nastiest, cattiest
privately.
And I think that's the reason why so many people are annoyed
by her. You should just let the demons out.
You should that
it's so I I think XC is funny. I I think XC is funny here. Okay.
He's like, "Oh,
I was I was in for I was in for a little snark and I got way
too much. I got way more than I >> That's who you really
are. We know that's who you are. >> It's obvious. Everybody
knows it. >> So, like this really fake PR thing where like
you never want to >> Okay, chat. Now I'm um now I'm starting
to think about a version where Pokemon man didn't reach as much
success as she's gone uh over the over the past decade right
where she was kind of like
here's questions like cheated on his girlfriend with like 20
Vtubers why are XQC and Asmin on his side because there's this
thing where if you don't do the allegation or whatever it wasn't
a rip allegation in the first place if you don't do whatever
allegation against a streamer perfectly these guys are just
I'm sorry They
they don't want their uninterrupted stream of teenagers to end
anytime soon. Okay, that's that's how I feel about it most of
the time is just these guys, you know, they they take advantage
of the situation. They're happy about it. They're good. They're
they're thriving and they don't really want the status quo to
change at all. So, they they don't like these things at all.
They just they like oppose them unless they're perfect. They
have to be absolute knockouts. Also, the Syikuna thing, I think
some reasonable people could oppose it. There are people who
just think you shouldn't put your private business on the internet
unless there are crimes happening, right? Like if it's if it's
like assault, you can put it on the internet. But if it's just
like I got cheated on and I feel really hurt, there are a lot
of reasonable people who think that should never go on the internet.
Now, I think with Syikuno, my personal opinion was that I'm fine
with that being on the internet cuz he's using the internet to
find these women and he's lying and
exposing the tactics sort of takes the teeth out of it. So, that's
just me. But yeah, there's some there's some reasonable people
who think that way as well, not just these guys. >> Let's
say more on the on the lower middle end, right? And she just
went full demon time. Like she just like ripped it like the olden
days. Like just [__] it. Today we're doing cheat
review 3.0. Today we're doing you know what I
>> Say anything. It's just annoying. Yo yo,
>> don't worry guys.
No, that's all I'll say. I want to feel your body. >> Oh
my god. Jesus. >> It's okay. It's >> dude. I I'm
probably like actually quite similar to XC and how I receive
stuff sometimes. Like I could just tell I can tell Pokemon's
little mannerisms piss some people off so much. Like just her
little her existing just makes people rage just see and it kills
me. Like I I get so much joy out of watching people see the Pokemon.
Like it's so funny to me every time. And Teone's on break. So
Asmin Gold's taking up that slack. >> Flippers hate me
as long as I feel like I said what I >> like. Like like
it's just she just does this little like hum to herself. >> Don't
worry guys.
No, that's all I'll say.
>> I want to feel your body right. >> Oh my god.
Jesus. >> It's okay if Clippers hate me as long as I feel
like I said what I meant and I meant what I said. There will
be >> You never say anything. >> That's what's >> Okay,
that's what I said. >> It's going to happen nine times
out of 10. One time out of 10 I might be like, "Oh, I didn't
say that the way that I meant." But >> Jesus watching.
Jeez. Oh my god. Well, she's so It's just Yes. Please. It's just
nuts, man. And uh Yeah, it's nuts. Please stop torturing us.
Wow. What a what a um what a clip. vague posting. I know it's
just outrageous. >> What a clown.
>> I mean, it's Jack, guys. It is It is pretty clown. It's
pretty It's pretty jester. You want the idea of what a gesture
is that? I mean, she's kind of gesturing a little bit. >> It's
pretty clown. It's pretty jester.
well, because >> you know what he really wanted to say?
What a dumb. I mean, I just throw those out, man. Those feel
those feel cathartic to throw out. When you got to throw them
out, you got to throw them out. Okay. Guys, you can kind of tell,
and I don't mean to be rude. I'm sure we all getting the vibe.
You can kind of tell she's like disappointed that he didn't lose
more. Disappointed that he didn't like like catch the full force
of the internet. Like he's not like GG. You know what I mean?
Honestly,
I think the thing Pokey might have similar thoughts to me. I
just think the thing is like
I didn't I didn't like that generally the public opinion I felt
like at some point was, "Oh, he didn't really do anything wrong."
That annoyed me.
But realistically, if I just if I want the public to always agree
with me, like I'm going to never be happy in my entire life.
So, we just don't
don't take that seriously. Okay.
It's like, hey, yeah, I wanted more people to be annoyed about
it. They weren't. And I was like, oh well, I'll move on. I'll
move on. It's not that big a deal. It is what it is.
All right. Okay. I think we're basically done with this guy.
Oh, yeah. He's he's saying, well, Pokey wanted him to suffer
more. I think Pokey just felt like he's kind of a piece of and
nobody really thinks he's a piece of or at least a lot of people
online don't think he's a piece of
and that's that's dissonance could just feel weird that's all.
Oh, is this the same one? No, this is a different clip that he
commented on. >> I'm also someone like I don't listen to
um sad music.
Couldn't pay me. >> Oh, he doesn't listen to sad music
to um sad music.
Couldn't pay me. >> I'm a happy golucky gal and I like
to stay that way.
It's kind of true. Like guys,
which of you guys have been here many many years?
Like I'm talking you've been following me like six plus years.
A lot of my ops they really are.
Have you ever thought about that?
But don't train wrecks have like $300
I feel like that you you might say that feel like Trainrex is
sitting on his pile of gold like a dragon in a cave.
I don't know if I don't know if Train Wreck's lost, man. He's
looking at buying sports franchises and
>> I'm still here.
You know,
guys, I think Oh, it uploaded.
>> You complain about denims being smug that this is like
10 times worse. It's not 10 times worse, though, is it?
There's something about Denims only doing the smile that makes
it worse. Pokey is just like Pokey is fully in that energy unless
like explicitly trying to do that and that makes it funnier in
a way. It's like Denims is not trying to do that. Denims is like
trying to hold it in but she can't. Denims is like trying to
hold it in and trying to like not be that way but she actually
is that smug and she actually feels that way. Anyway, Pokey is
like trying to make people annoyed which is funny to me at least.
Okay. All right. Oh, I didn't even look at the techone reply.
That's the only reason I watched that was to look at the techone
reply, which was
Pokemon is 30 years old. She was born in May on May 14th, 1996.
You can read more about her background and content creation journey
on Wikipedia.
So cool. This Techone guy.
What a cool
Asmin Gold agreed with Willax tweets. William Max tweet shouldn't
do anything wrong in this clip, but she still manages to come
off as horribly unlikable. It's truly her greatest
As Pokemon is to unlikability, Willie Mack is to illiteracy and
ignorance. So, yes, I I do agree. You both have an innate talent
for both for for those things. Yes. Yes, Willy Mack. Yes.
God, Willy Mack is annoying. Okay,
I'm gonna do maybe we'll grab I think I was going to grab a couple
Denims clips to play real quick before we get into the actual
content for the day. All right. Oh, hold on. I realized something.
They see that white presenting women are 30 and acting like a
teen or whatever, but they glaze Asian women for being 30 and
looking 12 or whatever. Um, they also don't act like 30-year-old
men,
I not that I'm throwing the first stone on that one. You know
what I mean? Not that I'm throwing the first stone, but come
on. All right. I think this clipping wings accounts
has some of these denims clips from today.
Watch maybe a couple of these Denims clips from today. Her reacting
to stuff. She reacted to the Fant thing.
>> next to Fant explaining Ethan Klein is just mad that
he's being criticized. >> You're getting criticized. Are
some of those criticisms unfair and are they coming from like
weird terminally on online psychos that are on Reddit or this
platform or that platform? Yeah, I'm sure some of them are. I
>> I mean like the reality is if you exist on the internet
and you're even if you're not controversial, but if you're even
a little bit controversial,
like the reality is that people are just going to make up about
you and they're going to be annoying towards you. And Ethan knows
that.
Like Mr. Beast explicitly did like this corporate politically
correct thing where he never offends anybody and then they just
started talking about how he's the antichrist.
You know what I mean? Like no matter what, no matter what, people
will talk about you on the internet. It doesn't matter what your
persona is. It doesn't matter what you're doing. Now with Ethan,
I think the thing that hurts is that some of the critiques are
And that's probably the thing that gets at him, right? is some
of the critiques are accurate. I feel like when critiques are
totally inaccurate, when they're totally wrong, they've missed
entirely. I do think they tend not to hurt as much.
It's like accurate critique or accurate critique that's like
twisting something. Those are the things that >> Like that's
like part as much as I don't want it to be part of the deal.
It's part of the deal with content that there are just freaks
on the internet that will talk about you and make up random about
you. Yeah. Like Miss Rachel. >> You're not totally wrong.
Oh, they hate Miss Rachel.
She's about to go to Miss Rachel. They said Miss Rachel's an
anti-semite.
Did you did it over some
You did it over some stupid,
mindless,
petty,
emotional. It's so crazy how so many of these same exact like
slop tubers fought pirate software for so long because pirate
software was not being very pirate software
and he was actively pushing for corporations to have more power
over consumers. And at the moment that it's just an enemy that
they like
they they like disliking. It's like yes corporations and people
with the most money possible they should have the power to do
whatever they want to the rest of us. Yes.
I uh that's a tough one. The stop killing games thing is a tough
one. >> It's like
>> I don't know if I agree with this one. >> Yeah,
I don't know if I agree with this one. I think the stop games
one was a little more than people are willing to
especially if you know anything about the technical side of making
software and maintaining systems like that. I just feel like
there's a bit more there, man. Like it there's just a bit more
and it's not quite that simple. I do think the stop killing games
thing was on the right track. There should be some, especially
if it's a live service game, there should be some aspect of being
able to continue to play the game. Some aspect of like you're
you're paying for something to be there. Yeah, I I do think that
should be something built into live service games.
But
the whole aspect of like, oh, people should be able to open source
the servers and run them themselves. I was like, oh, that's going
to be real tough. I don't know if you could possibly do that.
That feels like that would be a tough one. Okay,
one one or two more Denims clips and then we're going to get
into the H3 stuff. Okay. >> And so I was like, "Oh man,
this is when like the video dropped. I was so tired." So I was
like, "Let me just post like a little photo." And then I posted
this photo
like literally a normal photo of me and then this this comment
like it literally sent me like this is what the H3 fans look
like.
>> Infantilism face. I uh is is Denim's just cursed with
like having like a baby face, like a woman baby face.
Like I I do feel like there's a little bit of that there, right?
That I understand, but she's not like doing something with her
face. She just looks like she got
there's something about her face that it just looks young. Like,
>> and then this this comment like it literally sent me
like this is what the H3 fans look like. The infantilism phase
puke emoji.
Ohoo. So cute. Side smile. Gamergirl. Constant cleavage. Smo
smothered in makeup. Valley girl. Vocal fry. Not like other girls
with an OF filled with pedto bait. Much progressive like Hassan
talking about women. You set us back.
Okay. Can I just say a couple things? First of all, I set us
I set women back by posting a photo of my face. second >> like
it's a bit much, right? It's just a bit much.
This is a little crazy. This is a little too far. I would say
I I think you could easily say it's a little too far, man.
That's a pretty crazy comment. >> Smothering in makeup
is so amazing cuz like I'm not even wearing my my iconic eyeliner
in this one. Like I I >> Dude, I I can't even begin to
explain like how self-conscious women get out of nowhere if you're
like, "Oh, you're just like wearing a ton of makeup. You just
have makeup caked on." I I feel like they will have to explain
their entire usual routine versus the routine they did on this
day which is slightly off but still took like 35 minutes to do
like well I applied like this and then this and then this but
normally I have to do like this that this that this that this
that. It's like okay I get I get
That's fine.
It's fine. It's I I actually No, stop talking about it. Please
stop talking about it. I literally just put on my tinted moisturizer
because it doubles as
>> that that was about to go off into like a whole makeup
rant. I could feel it. It that was going off into an entire makeup
rant right there.
I know. I know. I I get it though. I feel bad. I I genuinely
feel bad for women having the like set standard that they have
to wear makeup. Guys just get to like roll out of bed, hop on
a stream. Women got to do the whole makeup thing or have like
a filter. I assume there's some kind of filter going on here,
but
it's actually that sucks. That's like a 45minute penalty on every
one of your days. It's
Lab trying to change that. I'm sure men would look better if
they wore makeup. It's just like you don't have to. It's not
it's not in it's not baked in. It's not price for it's not the
price of entry. You know what I'm saying? So you end up being
okay.